and now to this story we're following
this morning the manhunt is widening for
a gunman who recorded himself killing
someone
and posted the video on facebook
37-year-old steve stevens is accused of
gunning down a
74 year old man yesterday in cleveland a
warning while we will not show the
actual killing the video
you are about to see is graphic police
say that stevens calmly walked up to
robert
godwin senior and just opened fire the
victim was apparently chosen at random
stevens also bragged of other killings
dean reynolds is in cleveland with the
latest on the manhunt for him
dean good morning good morning well the
video of the killing was one of three
videos stevens posted yesterday
easter sunday in the others he described
himself as a man who
snapped who was angry at his mother his
ex-girlfriend
and his job and he claimed that he had
killed more people
though the cleveland police have seen no
evidence so far to back that
up i'm at the point watching that
in this video of the murder posted to
facebook police say 37-year-old steve
stevens
approaches robert godwin senior all
right
can you do me a favor he earlier told
the world that he was angry with his
ex-girlfriend
joy lane joy elaine yeah
she's the reason why um this is about to
happen to you
how old are you oh man
i joy lane issued a statement to cbs
news we had been in a relationship for
several years she said
i am sorry that all of this happened
stevens posted that this killing
was one of more than a dozen he
committed the male stated that he would
be in this area randomly shooting
people in the head i killed 13 so i'm
working on 14 as we speak
apparently there are no other victims
that we know of from what we can tell
now it's just a random person that he
picked out
we don't know why but again it's
senseless
guidewind's children say he had just
left a family easter celebration
i hate he's gone you know what i mean i
don't know what i'm gonna do
it feels like it's not real i feel like
my heart
is gonna stop i'm 37 and all my [ __ ]
life man i just always been a [ __ ]
monster man
steven's posts were online about three
hours before his page was taken down
facebook issued a statement this is a
horrific
crime and we do not allow this kind of
content on facebook
we are in touch with law enforcement in
emergencies
when there are direct threats to
physical safety hopefully
i'm gonna try to kill as many people as
i can be on death row or whatever the
case may be
now the fbi is also assisting in this
case
the cleveland police say that stevens
may have left the state
he is described as driving a white ford
fusion
with temporary tags anthony we hope they
catch him soon dean thank you very much